se tratará de realzar Los lazos
diplomáticos con los pocos aliados que
le quedan la presidente de Taiwán inicia
este viernes una visita oficial a
Guatemala y Belice en estar acompañada
su canciller quien declaró en su cuenta
de Twitter que ya la habían avisado de
que en ambas naciones tanto la gente
como el clima eran calurosos pero el
objetivo de Esta visita trasciende el
solo turismo efectivamente desde hace
unos años Guatemala y Taiwán vienen
consolidando una relación de cooperación
sobre todo desde la pandemia cuando
Taiwán fue el primero en ayudar a
Guatemala con donaciones de equipos
contra el covid 19 de hecho está
previsto que este fin de semana la
presidenta said visite aquí en Guatemala
el hospital de Chimaltenango una obra
que contó con el apoyo financiero de
Taiwán y que está considerada por
Alejandro yamate y el presidente de
Guatemala como el hospital más grande de
Centroamérica el gobierno de Guatemala
viene manifestando ante la comunidad
internacional su compromiso para velar
por la soberanía de La Isla frente a
Beijing quien considera a Taiwán como
parte de su territorio pero esta visita
de la presidenta de Taiwán interviene en
un momento crítico para la isla después
de que la presidenta de Honduras
Xiomara Castro anunciará a abandonar sus
relaciones con Taiwán para
restablecerlas con Beijing actualmente
13 estados siguen manteniendo relaciones
con la isla incluyendo Belice donde la
presidenta de Taiwán tiene previsto
reunirse con el Primer Ministro